one of those  you know  uh  good-natured streams  this is going to be one of the molding  ones  i can feel that coming  oh h6 uh i think yeah  played this against me before oh he's  played this as well  questions  okay queen e4 i can still as long as i  can keep the stronghold in the center  i'm i have good compensation  really this actually works  annoying  trying to get some grip on the  positioner  a4a5 a6 maybe  i am straw  this is brandon jacobson  okay i've played him before yeah yeah  i'm winning on position now  sorry  yeah with the time situation it should  be fine  okay which is roxy7  take g7 as well  okay  yeah technique is less than  optimal but it doesn't matter  g4 is a good premium